I think along these lines one thing
because I don't deal with this that
might have I was curious especially in
the world of directing well first of all
directing is very easy I mean writing
you can quite honestly just go up by
yourself and write a script you can't go
off by yourself and just make a movie
you know I mean it takes a lot of other
people and a lot of other aspects of it
but getting back to this whole thing of
resistance from family or friends or
even from inside people who you know
they deal with the old doubts and I deal
with you know with a lot of directors
you know who say you think I'm good at
again do you think I'm good enough and
look at my little film my little short
film like a little short film you think
it you know I could make it the only
thing I can ask them which I've done
several times I say listen I want you to
imagine that you stopped directing right
now you know what because they think I'm
telling them that they shouldn't I said
I'm not telling you shouldn't I just
imagine you stop directing right now and
you never never do it ever again you
okay with that because if they say yeah
I said well there's your answer
if they said no I can't you know I'm
what I'm looking for is that passion no
I had this is something I have to do I
have to keep going and it's that passion
that will push you up against all those
obstacles whether it's family friends
raising money whatever if there is no
strong enough passion that this is the
thing I must be doing I can't imagine I
mean I've talked to director says I
can't imagine doing that I don't know
what I would do I don't know what other
that's it if you had to get another kind
of job I don't know what else I would do
this is the only thing I know how to do
and this is the only thing I want to do
I said okay good then we're gonna keep
doing it and I think it is again
regardless of the quality it's the drive
the internal drive innocent is that an
internal thought that voice somewhere
inside you because I know and I'm
guessing that Michael has the same thing
I know that inside my career has been
driven by some kind of voice that says
keep doing this even though this that
I'm doing now is not what I plan to do
I'm doing less directing and more
teaching
something had said keep going with that
something kept driving me then I
realized how much I enjoyed teach I got
one deck then I guess this is what I
need to be doing and I think that's what
we have to get in this a little bit wait
your time I get in touch with that if
you can get in touch with that and
realize that that's part of you not
because I want to make movies and I want
to move to Hollywood and I want to do or
make a lot of money because that's not
the reason to do this first thing I was
going to say is personal just when you
reach that point where you stop thinking
what should I be doing and just turn
around for me it was turning around
realized I love this I love this and I
had always long ago thought well people
would always ask me well if you know I
was about story and screenplays why
aren't you a screenwriter and I there
was always a part of me that didn't want
to hear that you know because deep down
I thought yeah I should be if I'm
settling and finally I realized no I
tried it and it was hard but also it
wasn't it wasn't where I lived it wasn't
my passion this is what I love I love
talking as you can see I love talking
about story moving I love helping people
with their stories but I was also going
to add in light of what you said I also
think that what Mark is saying about go
after the passion and you got to keep
doing that that's ultimately the road to
success that all those other the the
reason you shouldn't be going after it
the money and so on is more likely to
come if you're going after it because
it's your passion I mean if you listen
to interviews with successful people in
the film industry especially the
creative the really created the
directors the writers the actors I
remember I saw Paul Newman interviewed
eons ago and he said you know when I
came along there were better actors they
were better-looking guys but nobody was
as tenacious as I was I just wanted it
more and I've seen that again and again
with screenwriters I people email me or
I work with people and they say oh I
can't get anybody to read my script and
I can't get an agent and so on and
they're still you know diddling around
with the same script they were working
on three years ago
and the ones who make it or the ones
that just I write every day I write I
write and I write and I write and I
cranked out scripts and they get better
and better but they just keep going
after it if you really are tenacious
you're more likely to succeed than any
other quality including Talent I think
you